75 يوما فقط تفصل الشارع التركيه على
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه التي
ستجرى مع تاكيد اردوغان على ان الموعد لم
يتغير وسيكون بتاريخ 14 من مايو المقبل
وفق تقرير صادر عن وكاله بلومبرج تمر
المعارضه التركيه بازمه خانقه بسبب الفشل
في الاتفاق على مرشح مشترك لمنافسه الرئيس
التركي الذي اتهم الاحزاب المعارضه
بالفوضى والانقسام بشان قضايا تتعلق
باداره البلاد على حسب تعبيره
ليكن هذا واضحا للجميع هذه الامه ستفعل ما
هو ضروري في الرابع عشر من مايو الشعب
التركي سيرد على هؤلاء المغرضين ولن يابه
لمن يرددون الشعارات والمقولات الفارغه
توحيد جبهه المعارضه في هذه الانتخابات
بات ضروريه لكسب المعركه السياسيه وفق
مراقبين وفشلوا الحكومه في التعاطي مع
عمليات الانقاذ والاغاثه سيشكل ورقه رابحه
بالنسبه لها حيث ان قاده الطاوله السداسيه
للمعارضه التركيه تقول انها ستعلن خلال
ايام مرشحها المشتركه لخوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه ووسط التكهنات المتداوله اكد
زعيم الحزب الصالح القومي التركيه المعارض
ان الحزب لن يستسلم لمحاولات محاصرته حيث
طرح ترشيح رئيس بلديه انقره من سوريا واش
ورئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو لخوض
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لكن الاحزاب الخمسه
الاخرى لم تقبل بذلك وقامت بترشيح كمالكا
لجدار اوغلو لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه
تضارب التصريحات طرح السيناريوهات
المتعدده ابرزها خرو ج المعارضه باكثر من
مرشح بهدف ارباك ساحه المؤيدين للرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان وسط تحليلات تشير الى ارتفاع
حدود المعارضه في تحقيق فوز على اردوغان
بعد كارثه الزلزال من جهه او تصويت اقل من
نصف ناخبين لصالح حزب العداله والتنميه ما
سيسمح للرئيس التركي بالتغلب في صناديق
الاقتراع